[Music]
uh my name is um
len
and i'm from venezuela but i live in
florida and my question is about
drinking i know you stopped drinking
long time ago and i'm in the process
and i would like to know if you can
recommend a group
i feel like i'm ready my body is ready
my mind is ready but
i cannot picture
um
i cannot picture socializing without it
and i want to know if you can help in
any way
like a link
community
anything will help
thank you wow what a great call thank
you so much for that question so brave
and
makes what makes you feel all like good
inside um
yeah uh first of all uh when i decided
to stop drinking i could not imagine
life
socializing i was like i like for
example i love baseball and i remember
thinking well i'll never i'm obviously
never going to a baseball game again
because why would anybody go to a
baseball game if they can't drink a beer
what's the point
and i remember thinking well i'm never
going to celebrate new year's again
i mean
what's the point and i remember thinking
well i'm never going to have fun at the
4th of july again
and um and listen for the first year i
just did other things
like i didn't put pressure on myself
to enjoy those things in the way i did
drinking i found i would do something
else fun
on that
during that time and
i got to be honest that lasted for me
i don't even think it lasted a year
i think literally within the first year
i was like [ __ ] it i don't
i don't need to drink for this
because you've said you've already said
the key thing you think you're ready
and when you're ready you're ready you
know you can't be ready for your
because your boyfriend wants you to do
it or your
dad thinks you should stop drinking or
you got a dwi and you're worried about
your license none of that work no nobody
care if that's isn't gonna ever ever
ever ever
do it
you have to be ready and you you led
with that so congrats and you know look
um
you know
obviously a lot of people have been
helped with alcoholics anonymous
um i'm a big believer in that you can
there there's gonna be you can just dial
in you know information in your
community
uh for the aaa hotline
and they will provide you with meetings
and uh
it's it's a it's a great fellowship um
and i would recommend that as the first
step
and uh and and see if you feel at home i
guess as you're gonna be and uh
congratulations uh it's a it's a great
choice and it's a great journey um i
would i would i would it's the best
thing i ever did
by far and i have more fun today than i
ever had in the days when i was uh
drinking and drugging and doing all this
stuff and and by the way i had a lot of
fun doing that
and i'd still be doing it if it worked
for me
but it stopped
so so did i alright thank you that was
great great call